[Music]  this is Will Robinson of the 24th  colorist group I'm making a record of  this because it seems we're the first  humans to try engine spaceship or  sailboat Anchors Away  [Music]  carrot waterfall we just get where we're  going once without crashing  I love you guys  [Music]  feud about the robot I wish she was here  too much we need to find two we have to  at least try their robot is the key to  our survival  [Music]  everyone else they want to know why from  us  [Music]  we need to get out of here and leave all  this behind we have to protect ourselves  normal is out there somewhere  just have to fight it  excuse me I didn't get a job your job is  to do nothing and touch nothing she  never likes to when someone else saves a  day  [Music]  keep each other safe  [Music]  Robinson can anybody hear me  [Music]  do we really have to do this  [Music]